The Scarlet King.
It says something that in a multiverse full
of terrifying, world-ending monsters like
The Sealed King, the Hanged King - a lot of
Kings, come to think of it - The Crimson Khan
himself overpowers them all.
But today we want to pose and hopefully answer
an interesting question: How actually powerful
is The Scarlet King?
After all, he’s apparently the greatest
threat that the Foundation has ever faced,
we’d be fools to not analyze what we’re
dealing with as an adversary here.
Despite his exploits being well-documented,
there’s a lot about the Scarlet King’s
personal life we still don’t know.
What’s he doing to pass the time in that
Multiversal Void while awaiting his minions
to open a portal into our world?
Does he have friends?
Fulfilling hobbies?
Do you think he watched Sxquid Game, like
the rest of us?
We just don’t know.
Because of these gaps in our knowledge, we’re
taking a pretty wide definition of “power”
here.
We’re not only going to analyze the presumed
abilities of the King himself, but also his
reputational and institutional power - Including
the abilities of the allies and henchmen in
his thrall.
And of course, to keep things balanced, we’re
also going to take a look at his weaknesses,
both potential and confirmed, to get a bigger
picture of the net power of the Scarlet King.
So grab your prophetical Daevite tablets and
find a grungy occult warehouse near you - We’re
gonna find out just how powerful the King
of the Darkness Below really is.
First thing’s first: What exactly is the
Scarlet King?
According to the lore given to us by the Dust
and Blood tablet, he’s technically an elder
God born into a whole race of godlike beings
in the vast abyss below the tree of life.
Already, before he even developed his later
powers, it’s clear this puts the Scarlet
King into an entirely different weight class
to any human beings, even anomalously enhanced
ones like Able or Dr. Bright.
It’s very likely that the Scarlet King’s
very understanding of the concepts of life
and death differ greatly from what we mere
mortals think about the subject.
But the Scarlet King isn’t your grandad’s
Elder God: He spent the first eons of his
life becoming the greatest warlord that the
Multiverse has ever known, killing and consuming
his own siblings in order to amass greater
domination over the darkness below.
As he slaughtered his way through the ancient
divine hierarchy, he not only expanded his
territory, he honed his skills as a combatant.
Even against Elder Gods his own size, the
Scarlet King is an almost unstoppable warrior,
either slaughtering his godly foes or scaring
them so much that they bend the knee to him
and devote the rest of their lives to service.
In short, even without any of his allies or
anomalous powers, he’s a true master when
it comes to one on one combat.
The Scarlet King is also the kind of tyrant
who leads from the front, wanting to get even
more red on his iconic crimson armor.
After all, what’s the fun in starting wars
with everyone if you don’t get to bask in
the glorious thrill of bloodshed and mass
carnage, right?
The Scarlet King is a big believer in loving
what you do.
Point is, we’re looking at a warrior king
who can slaughter gods and goddesses with
his bare hands, and takes great pleasure in
doing so.
To him, humans are unusually intelligent ants,
mocking him with their love of life, peace,
order, and science…Well, for the most part,
anyway.
Physically, he’s astonishingly powerful,
but that still leaves him with certain handicaps.
For example, his ability to traverse dimensions
is not what he wants it to be.
Thanks to the tireless work of groups like
the SCP Foundation, every single one of his
attempts to physically enter our universe
has failed.
However, this doesn’t mean that he doesn’t
have the power to at least influence our world,
even if he hasn’t quite gotten the opportunity
to personally slam dunk planet earth into
the sun yet.
The Scarlet King, like a lot of eldritch beings
beyond human comprehension, is able to drive
human beings insane with the mere scope of
his abilities, having easily broken the mind
of Dr. Montauk when he learned of the Scarlet
King’s true nature.
The Scarlet King is also capable of bringing
out the worst in people, projecting his boundless
desire for cruelty and malice into those vulnerable
to him.
As a truly ancient being, he’s had eons
of experience, and could easily outsmart and
destroy the psyche of any non-anomalous human
being arrogant or foolish enough to try to
face him.
From his SCP-001 file as well as the classified
documents on Procedure 110 Montauk, we also
know that the Scarlet King is able to perceive
things in our dimension in a limited fashion.
While he isn’t truly omniscient outside
his own reality like our traditional perception
of the Abrahamic God, he can sense feelings
and energies, his favorites being hate, cruelty,
and violence.
However, this strength can also be used against
him thanks to the Foundation’s knowledge
of how the Scarlet King’s perceptive abilities
work.
For example, they were able to trick the Scarlet
King into buying their lie about Procedure
110 Montauk, simply through a massive and
coordinated information campaign that convinced
a huge number of people that Procedure 110
Montauk actually was a horrifying act of profound
inhumanity.
And if it worked once in this fashion, it
could be used to shield other things from
the Scarlet King’s knowledge, creating a
huge weakness for this would-be conqueror.
However, the Scarlet King doesn’t need to
wage his evil war alone.
He is, after all, the Scarlet King.
An evil monarch whose reign brings darkness
and barbarism, and as such, he’s indivisible
from the forces who help him carry out his
depraved goals.
This segues nicely into our next question
about the power level of the Scarlet King:
What exactly are his supposed armies?
Who are his boots on the ground?
We’ll start with human and human-adjacent.
Probably the most common of the groups that
the Foundation are forced to counter are Scarlet
King Cultists, such as members of groups like
the Children of the Scarlet King.
They may not be the largest group of interest,
or the most trained or well-funded, but they
have one thing over all the other GOIs: Truly
boundless depravity.
If you take a look over the full file for
SCP-231, not only will you feel like you need
a shower, you’ll also realize that there
isn’t anything these hooded monsters wouldn’t
do in service of their dark master.
Kidnapping and murder are the two more mild
crimes.
Like with most dangerous cults, the Scarlet
King’s followers are heavily decentralized
and may have nothing that easily pegs them
as his devotees.
The fact that he has human eyes and ears hidden
everywhere is an undeniable feather in the
King’s bloody crown.
But these non-anomalous cultists only amount
to a fraction of the King’s earthly forces.
He’s had human armies and civilizations
pledge allegiance to his cause over the course
of history.
Take, for example, SCP-3838 - The Nomads of
the 4th Dimensional Steppe.
These tribes of Turkmen Warriors exist in
the exact same place at vastly different points
in time, traveling via a mysterious ritual
and a magical yurt.
At least one of these tribes worship the Scarlet
King and have a vested interest in his rule
over all things.
But of course, no section about the armies
of the Scarlet King would be complete without
his biggest fans: A little extinct culture
known as the Daevites.
Well, extinct for now at least, because SCP-140
- An Incomplete Chronicle - always leaves
the possibility of their return as an open
question.
So who exactly were these ancient conquerors?
Just in case you’ve repressed the memory,
the Daevites were an entire society of hyper-violent
monsters that loved to use imperialism, slavery,
and subjugation to get whatever they wanted,
and killed all who defied them.
Think of them like the British Empire, with
more magic and less tea.
They based their entire civilizational philosophy
on the teachings and lifestyle of the Scarlet
King, which is to say: Absolute primal brutality
rules, and he who can stomp on everyone else
is the leader.
And of course, nobody stomps harder than the
Scarlet King.
If ever SCP-140 was exposed to too much ink
or blood, the Daevites would wind up ruling
the modern world, and in all likelihood, they’d
do it in the name of the Scarlet King.
But those are only his human and human-adjacent
servants.
For starters, he’s also got a legion of
conquered elder gods who’ve pledged fealty
to him, and are now some of the most loyal
warriors for their brutal tyrant of a boss.
However, even a legion of elder gods is nothing
compared to the Scarlet King’s generals:
Six of his seven daughters.
Funny, even the most evil nightmare being
ever conceived indulges in a little nepotism
here and there.
Though in his defense, it isn’t easy being
a single father - admittedly, that’s only
because he crushed their mother, the kind
goddess Sanna, to death in cold blood.
Each one of his daughters gives him access
to new armies and powers.
The golden child, A’tivik, brings tactical
brilliance and advanced knowledge of all things
warfare, with children who are equally well-versed
in the combat arts.
Then there’s A’ghor, who makes up for
what she lacks in quality with sheer, insane
quantity.
Her children have produced obscenely large
armies that can overwhelm their foes like
living tides of hatred and murder, all of
which are loyal to the Scarlet King himself.
Next, A’distat, a desolate daughter as mean
and hateful as her dear old dad.
Her armies charge forth, declaring victory
in the name of the King.
They also have the ability to spread devastating
pestilence with their mere presence, making
other armies deathly ill and probably making
SCP-049 feel extremely anxious.
He’s also got A’zieb, probably his biggest,
scariest daughter that appears in the form
of a giant, unstoppable beast.
Her armies are also bestial nightmares, and
she herself seems impossible to harm with
any mortal weapon.
There’s A’nuht, the Scarlet King’s frailest
daughter, but a natural when it comes to all
things magic.
She and her reality-warping children are actually
so powerful that the Scarlet King himself
felt a little threatened by them, and had
them all physically disabled.
Now, the Scarlet King has unfettered access
to powerful thaumaturgy at his disposal.
And then there’s A’tellif, his most mysterious
daughter who prides herself on privacy and
is, accordingly, a master in the art of stealth,
with her and her children having the ability
to change their faces and walk among people
unnoticed.
With such absurdly huge armies, a large number
of emissaries in our world, and six daughters
who grant him obscene and varied powers, it’s
clear that the Scarlet King truly is the most
powerful enemy that the SCP Foundation has
ever faced.
However, his most major weakness is his seventh
daughter and her offspring: A’habbat, the
child of hope, and the only daughter strong
in spirit enough to fight back against her
monstrous father.
Her children are great heroes, and one of
them is believed to be SCP-999, the Tickle
Monster.
The Scarlet King may have sown the seeds of
his own destruction, as it’s prophesied
that if SCP-999 is nurtured and continues
to grow, he may one day become strong enough
to defeat the Scarlet King’s evil with his
sheer force of good.
With all of these Scarlet King strengths,
powers, allies, and weaknesses I think we
can confidently answer the question: How actually
powerful is the Scarlet King?
To put it simply, he’s extremely powerful,
perhaps more powerful than anything else out
there.
But he’s still not invincible.
The next question is whether the Foundation
can identify the cracks in the Scarlet King’s
bloodstained armor before he enters our world,
and annihilates everything we know and love…
Now go check out “Children of SCP-001 The
Scarlet King - Is SCP-999 Really His Son?”
and “SCP-001- Scarlet King - Dust and Blood”
for more insider information on the first
word in pure, undiluted evil!